les droits de l'enfant en question
aujourd'hui à gouvieux dans l'oise 200
spécialistes venus de 4 us de 40 pays
étrangers vont continuer d'analysé en
présence de la secrétaire d'état à la
famille ellen dorlhac la convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant
une convention sur les droits et devoirs
des moins de 18 ans que la france a
ratifiera en 1990 le compte rendu de la
journée d'hier avec jean-claude assolant
le projet de convention des nations
unies sur les droits de l'enfant est en
fait le fruit d'un travail énorme
commencé dès 1924 par la déclaration de
genève en cinq articles
celle ci reconnaissait aux enfants
quelques droits fondamentaux la
protection contre l'exploitation entre
autres reprises en 1959 cette
déclaration se transformait en 10
principes basés sur le droit à la vie et
la protection dix principes dont
certains sont restés à l'état de voeux
pieux
si en europe une protection sociale et
évite les a vus il n'en est pas de même
dans les pays du tiers-monde alors et le
droit des enfants et 10 le même parcours
exact américain et il me semble la même
le même droit que pour la la société ark
donc tout les articles qui ont été cités
ces soins des instituts sont dus en
partie appliquée cinq hommes où la femme
africaine ou la famille africains
d'alger un droit codifiées mais ça se
passe ni duquel seuls enfants la vie
associative le droit au logement
protection de l'enfant en cas de cas de
conflit et vous savez il faut rappeler
une chose c'est que dans l'afrique
australe l'enfant n'était pas mêlé aux
conflits armés
il était à l'abri de guerre des adultes
1979 année internationale des enfants
annie des droits de l'homme les
responsables d'organismes bien connus
comme l'onu l'unesco l'unicef ont
franchi une nouvelle étape
ces symposiums se propose de faire le
point
sur les progrès réalisés pour ceux et
celles qui n'ont pas encore atteint les
18 ans force est de reconnaître qu'il
reste encore beaucoup à faire
il faut dire que la législation c'est
une première étape et je vous donnerai
un exemple très concrète manifoot les
spectateurs connaît très bien la réalité
des enfants de la rue les pédophiles qui
vole un bas pour abuser les enfants ils
ne peuvent pas être poursuites en
justice là bas pourquoi parce que la
législation n'existe pas alors on lui
donne une billet d'avion pour sortir
pour quitter le pays voilà merci c'est
fini ça doit finir à il faut que ces
gens soient poursuites en justice pour
que les enfants sont mais en une
meilleure protection à l'avenir
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
devraient adopter la nouvelle convention
et ainsi prouver une fois de plus que
l'enfance est une richesse irremplaçable